Arthur congratulations you won the
Battle of the Arthurs this was a
difficult game I guess an opponent sure
much lower rated but definitely in shape
in this tournament he showed it
yesterday how did you get ready for this
one what was your approach
um just the usual I mean like I just
wanted to get a game and that's what I
did
um
I think I played shaky chess to be
honest it was wild chess but it looked
quite interesting and this was perhaps
the critical moment right when he played
this move Rook to B5
after Queen to D2 it seems like you're
Gathering quite a significant Advantage
maybe Knight to D6 or something did you
spot this one and how did you assess
this yeah I did I I didn't really think
he played it I just played H4 because I
thought he would play Rook B5 yeah um to
stop you from going H5 exactly it was
just the most natural move he was
already getting like down to three
minutes here yeah and so I was just
playing off kind of intuition were you
uh happy with your position at this
point uh I mean that's it in your favor
I thought it was winning yeah like close
to winning at least
and then once you picked up but there
was there's a moment I got to it outside
that he had a chance wait at what point
um after F4 or 905 Queen C4 oh
okay Knight F5 Queen C4 yeah Rook D5 is
oh my gosh
oh this is waiting for you yeah did you
you spotted no no yeah we
I I didn't spot it that this is too hard
but he played like King h8 immediately
yeah but I got told outside Rook D5 is
just insane Rook D5 wins on the spot
yeah
wow what but by the way at this point
you guys both had well he had one minute
you had three minutes still a few moves
to go Rook to D5 was not played but
water blow yes and after King to h8 it
feels like
you kind of took over and never let it
go yeah after that
an important victory for you
um how is the preparation coming into
this event did you spend time looking at
the games of your opponents or what was
I don't really do much I've been playing
like five tournaments in a row so you've
been having a busy summer yeah yeah
exactly
um but yeah I mean the preparation here
was good
um he was like up to like move 18 or
something I was in prep but I mean
like I think I think prep doesn't really
matter that much these days especially
when there's so many like opportunities
for your opponent to go wrong so what do
you uh what attributes do you focus on
in your training to develop what skills
do you focus on
um I think
I think the biggest like
key for me was just to play like smart
chess and just like follow the
principles not getting careless in a way
um and like being able to just hold a
draw against these people because half
points are always you know important
especially in these tournaments so yeah
playing smart chess sticking to just the
principles thus like the basics you know
I don't think anything can go wrong
staying resilient playing Fighting Chess
that's definitely a good recipe
congratulations we'll see you in the
next rounds thanks congratulations
Arthur